[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission préférée si on parlait sport ce
talk est considéré comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive du département au
programme des coups de gueule des
analyses des débats et des duels vous
l'aurez compris ici pas de poudre de
perlimpinpin mais des spécialistes de
haut niveau
ils sont quatre sur le plateau
aujourd'hui pour vous faire vivre ce
sport yvelinois on commence on commence
les présentations en musique
à ma gauche c'est un pistard champion
d'europe sur piste dans la catégorie
masters il n'hésite pas à mouiller le
maillot à chacune de ses prestations
cette émission ce qui lui vaut une place
de titulaire et nous vient du club de
vélizy mesdames et messieurs ian
dujarrier est avec nous pour cette
émission bon sens michael moore soir
yann alors vous avez recharger les
batteries depuis le temps qu'on ne vous
a pas eu un seul bateau fait un petit
mois que je ne suis pas venu en effet un
trade attaque il a fait travailler un
petit peu et puis on continue d'ailleurs
en parler cyclisme notamment dans cette
émission les durs ce que notre
spécialiste en legends le thème les
durand noms du cyclisme tout à fait on
passe de l'autre côté à music inc un
droit de plaisir c'est un cavalier
international est un boxeur en refaire à
chaque émission il gratifie de ces
analyses sportives 2 de son sens de la
répartie dans ce talk on le surnomme le
zorro heavy nouara boycotterait de trait
est avec nous pendant une heure bonjour
à houlle bonjour michael alors on va
parler du jumping international de
versailles dans cette émission dont suis
ravi pareil vous êtes vous êtes le
spécialiste sur ce thème vous avez des
arguments tout à fait mais pas pu
m'appeler sans les par les choix non
j'étais moi-même justement en train de
courir une épreuve donc mais je les ai
suivis de très près donc voilà j'ai mes
informations
on repasse à droite musique on ne
présente plus c'est l'un des coaches les
plus respectés de la région parisienne
c'est soufflante à la mi temps et
pendant les matchs vont trembler les
murs du stade robert barran de plaisir
le coach de rugby genlis nous honore de
sa présence une nouvelle fois dans cette
émission
bonjour genre bonjour google alors je
crois ou savoir que vous êtes un homme
heureux
sportivement en ce moment comme j'ai dit
pour l'instant content heureux du match
vedette à 16h trad
donc on parlera de plaisir a notamment
dans cette émission merci en termine à
ma droite à ma gauche pardon musique
contrairement à moi allaient arrive à
allier souplesse et dextérité cette
spécialiste de la pole dance un sport
qui mêle danse acrobatie autour d'une
barre à n'a pas froid aux yeux
notre ambassadrice de charme hélène de
la grange nous fait l'honneur de venir
sur cette émission
bonjour bonjour hélène scherrer émission
je rêvais d'être avis ouais sainté qui
vous allez progresser par rapport à la
dernière émission s'est pas engagé vous
allez gagner l'expérience warendin
d'ingérer visu ok on va voir ça je vous
rappelle les règles vous avez donc une
petite raquette pour répondre aux
questions vous avez le choix entre eux
oui ou non il ya également une petite
ardoise
il ya tout pour nous présenter cette
petite ardoise voilà vous faites vous
faites dans cette émission
donc la petite ardoise vous pouvez
marquer ce que ce qui vous passe par la
tête tout simplement donc hélène
n'hésitez pas à demander aux garçons si
vous avez besoin besoin d aide
on va passer vingt ans bonjour voila ça
marche très bien on va passer maintenant
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de boxe notamment de
l'élan courtois a dit lahm on m'a dit
qui est devenu champion d'europe
à 36 ans nous évoquerons également la
visite du cio le lundi 15 mai dans les
yvelines
comment les séduire pour qu'il choisisse
paris en 2024
nous allons essayer de répondre à la
question avec les chroniqueurs mais
avant de développer ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur les performances
stratosphériques des rugbymans de
plaisir
le rugby-club de plaisir n'est qu'à plus
qu'à une marche de la montée en fédérale
2 ce dimanche 7 me les bleu et jaune au
récit leur meilleure prestation de la
saison contre marcq en baroeul pourtant
favori de la rencontre
après une première période convaincante
ponctuée par un 19 à 16
les plaisirs oies ont accéléré pour
marquer deux essais en seconde période
score final 31 à 16
on écoute la réaction du capitaine
françois le vilain à la fin de la
rencontre
aujourd'hui on était présent au combat
quoi devant on était bien et on sait
très bien trouver derrière les gars ont
fait des super mouvement ça d'ailleurs
été au bout est quasiment à chaque fois
donc donc du coup globalement le
collectif ont été très bons aujourd'hui
l'état d'esprit était top donc je pense
que c'est ce que c'est ce qui a
fonctionné
après cette performance les plaisirs wa
n'auront pas le temps de se reposer le
match pour retour est programmé dès ce
dimanche 14 mai sur le terrain de marcq
en baroeul joue à domicile ou à
l'extérieur change-t-il la donne nous
avons posé la question aux joueurs
plaisir roi à la fin de la rencontre
ben à domicile on sent qu'on a le publia
le public est là pour nous encourager la
semaine dernière on avait on avait nos
gars de la baie qui étaient là pour nous
encourager nous ont extrêmement
extrêmement aider dans cette victoire on
peut parler vraiment de d'un seizième
homme qui est là nous pousser et du coup
je vais à domicile ça c'est toute la
différence pour ça bah quand même très
domicile ou comme et on a plus nos
marques ont en plus nos repères nos
petites habitudes avant le match mais
après pour le match en soi ça change pas
grand chose quoi c'est surtout du mental
quoi je pense que mark va avoir chez eux
va être va avoir à coeur de faire la
même prestation ne pas perdre chez deux
parce que devant leur public ils vont
vouloir tout donner
genlis ils ont l'air heureux vos joueurs
qu'on les voit comme ça à la fin de
rencontre c'est normal c'est normal la
voulait parler à chaud après une belle
victoire dimanche dernier bouton marcq
en baroeul sont moins drôle fin
d'entraînement le mardi soir par exemple
où mark hollis mason a connu deux on en
est resté à deux non mais ça c'est
normal c'est normal y sont ils sont
encore sous l'euphorie et sous la
motivation il était encore son nom
toujours toujours sur vous l'abus
d'alcool est encore dangereux pour la
santé
à chaque émission ça ne change pas parce
que la question sur ce thème
est ce que c'est vraiment différent de
jouer à domicile ou à l'extérieur
oui ou non c'est un mythe ou une réalité
oui ou non vous êtes unanimes sur la
question
donc ça change quelque chose de vraiment
différent la question suivante alors
pourquoi
kilian pourquoi une une motivation qui a
été décuplé l'envié de faire plaisir à
son propre à son public on l'a vu en
2015 lorsque les championnats du monde
de cyclisme n'avait organisé au violon
de saint quentin une très belle moisson
pour pour l'équipe de france en 98 on
organise la coupe du monde et puis les
français sont champions du monde
pareil pour le championnat et à son
retour d'europe cette année on est en
finale
voilà donc
on peut simplement dire ça décuple est
certainement certainement la pression et
la pression est positive quand quand on
est à domicile soit le niveau de la
compétition
vous êtes d'accord ouais je pense que
c'est un ascendant après il peut être
aussi il peut être aussi négatif si on
se repose sur ses lauriers et
l'adversaire peut au cas où il joue à
l'extérieur avoir une une envie
supplémentaire de surmonter donc je dis
surtout que c'est un ascendant parce que
le sport de contact comme un sport de
contact comme le rugby est ouvert comme
la boxe le l'ascendant psychologique est
très déterminant
pour être en pleine possession de ses
moyens dans une confrontation physique
il faut avoir un ascendant psychologique
je pense pour pour se monter donc dans
quel sens je pense qu'il ya pas de règle
dans tous les cas oui c'est important ce
côté du coc tennis que ça marche mieux
organes pas souvent hollande gens me
disent que vous en pensez de cette
formule de jouer à l'extérieur à
domicile qu'est ce que ça change
sa charge tout simplement parce que à
domicile ils ont mis résumé tous les
deux mais sur les gars domicile et ya
aussi trois fleuves détroit n'y a que
deux qui me parlait ah oui ces trois
mois je parlais de raul et je pensais
que sur le plat nouveaux joueurs n'ont
pas d'eau pas de mes joueurs donc je
pars l'école mais jouer et c'est vrai
que jouer à domicile les joueurs ont
leurs repères en leur habitude ont
souvent leur famille qui est présente
sur le banc du terrain ou dans les
tribunes le public comme on l'a dit raúl
est aussi ce ce petit plus que ce que
fait défaut en public parce qu'ils aient
un peu de moins de 15 minutes je parle
pour le rugby puisqu'on parle pour le
rugby est particulièrement pur plaisir
et avec le monde mais qui est un peu
dans les tribunes en ce moment c'est
vrai que ça pousse ça pousse une équipe
on parle du seizième homme en rugby mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça fait la
différence notable plus que l'image
prochain quand on ira chez eux à marcq
en baroeul dans le nord
je peux vous assurer que là bas ça va
être très très difficile et très
compliqué à gérer surtout la première
demi heure
hélène l'un des joueurs de plaisir à
souligner le fait également de jouer sur
un terrain qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément on connaît pas les
infrastructures on connaît pas la
pelouse également est ce que ça change
quelque chose d'aussi haut niveau du
rugby ou même d'un autre sport de ne pas
connaître les lieux je pense que de
toute façon on préfère être à l'endroit
qu'on a l'habitude de fréquenter avec
nos habitudes
entouré par les proches entouré par les
gens qui nous suivent et caetera et ça
marche aussi dans pour les terrains ça
marche aussi pour les régions donc oui
je pense que ça fait vraiment une
différence
il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de
choses quand on dans la proche d'une
compétition et c'est vrai que le fait de
se dire aujourd'hui je sais où je vais
je sais où est ce que j'ai posé mon sac
comment je vais positionner tout ça
c'est des choses de baky qui permettent
de ne se rassurer ouais complètement et
du coup ça enlève du stress qui est
avant avant le match et ça ça mais ça
met dans de meilleures conditions le
fait de le fait de débuter son match et
de deux voilà il ya beaucoup de pensées
parasites canton quand on vient sur un
lieu où même nom vélo on court en cours
rarement enfin moins souvent à domicile
qu'à l'extérieur mais c'est vrai que
quand on vient sur une compétition où on
a déjà fait de la course
on connaît déjà le parcours mais tout ça
c'est des questions qui qui sont évacués
dès la fin tout de suite on se les
posent même plus de toute façon parce
qu'on connaît l'environnement et on sait
ce qui sur quoi on va tomber
où est ce qu'on va les chercher son
dossard où est ce qu'on va aller
voir les juges à l'arrivée où va être
ligne de départ où va être ligne
d'arrivée toutes ces choses là donc
belle sont elles sont balayées et c'est
vrai que ça facilite beaucoup ça enlève
du stress peut-être complètement ses
dépenses et les points de repère sur
intérêts mais quand on est à domicile on
connaît son terrain on a des points de
repères qu'on n'a pas forcément à
l'extérieur parce qu'on connaît pas on
connaît pas on connaît pas le terrain
donc
pourtant nous verra est le même dans le
terrain le même certes mais
l'environnement n'est pas le même et
forcément camou jouer chez vous ça c'est
humain vous avez vos repères vous avez
les repères l'environnement et on se
sent mieux et on a une petite
appréhension - forcément tous les
terrains sont pas identiques 1 il s'est
passé pas tracé vous mettre fin au mètre
près il al'argent le disney serait
respectée au rugby comme au football
d'ailleurs le terrain du barça et le
terrain plus large
c'est une légende apparemment le terrain
d'accord ça il a été rétrécie et
justement pour pourvoir aux normes et sa
date des années 30 avec raul il ya
également peut-être aussi une différence
au niveau au niveau des sports peut-être
le rugby le football c'est peut-être pas
la même chose au niveau de l'eau à
domicile ou à l'extérieur parce que
c'est exactement ce que je disais c'est
moi c'est par rapport au fait que j'ai
justement des contacts je pense que pour
aller au contact avec conviction il faut
absolument être bien dans sa peau pour
ne pas y aller de ne pas aller dans la
demi mesure
alors il faut pas non plus tomber dans
la complaisance le pas non plus tomber
dans le confort de son de son bercail
mais voilà les sports de contact se
singularise pour ça faut être bien dans
sa peau pour aller se faire mal et ne
pas avoir peur de le faire je pense que
au niveau du square zuccotti est-ce que
vous avez une idée laine de sport ou
c'est peut-être un peu différent je sais
pas au niveau la pole dance parents
quand vous allez vous produire dans
d'autres villes ça change quelque chose
ou pas c'est pareil
claire pareil si on pouvait emmener son
propre matériel on le ferait son propre
matériel on a des hauteurs de barques on
va préférer des épaisseurs de marque on
va préférer donc je pense que c'est un
peu la même chose
le sol aussi qu'on a préférés
on s'est séparés c'est également
peut-être plus d'impact gens mis sur les
matches à enjeu
là on voit qu'on est dans un match à
enjeu élimination directe ça joue
peut-être encore joue plus que
d'habitude
bien sûr la nausée et domicile et
extérieur oui ça joue parce que ce sont
des matchs cooper et comme on dit dire
que si demain je ne passe pas de la
saison est terminée
ouais donc si forcément forcément c'est
pas mal je poule ou dans le championnat
vous pouvez perdre un match c'est pas ça
va pas mettre en jeu votre votre saison
comme hélas oui là ce sont des matches à
élimination directe maintenant puisque
ce deuxième match mais il ya une des
deux équipes qu'on va finir la saison
j'espère que ce sera l'adversaire juste
tant que j'ai la parole je voulais juste
signaler la performance de notre équipe
réserve qui jouera dimanche aussi à côté
de rennes en quarts de finale du
championnat de france d'excellence b ce
dimanche 14 mai oui donc on a les deux
équipes se disant gagné au match aller
je crois 50 à 30 ans il n'y a pas de
match aller là c'est vrai que là des
matches couperets donc ils ont gagné et
32e 57,0 à côté 16e 20 ya 3 et les
huitièmes dimanche dernier contre marcq
en baroeul contre la réserve de marcq en
baroeul 54 51 3 et ils jouent dimanche
en quart de finale du championnat de
france
la réserve à plaisir au sérieux donc et
de la réserve il ya deux belles égalé
choix à faire aujourd'hui deux belles
équipes rôle pour que chez les noms sur
la feuille de match
alors comment fait également pour
préparer les joueurs à jouer à
l'extérieur raul comment les préparer ce
qu'on les prépare un peu différemment
parce que vous avez des conseils
peut-être à donner à genlis un an mais
j'ai surtout avant ce match retour tout
pas mais je pense que la stratégie s'est
essayé de recentrer vraiment le
collectif sur la sur la
justement la stratégie qui est mis en
place et de faire abstraction au maximum
des éléments extérieurs
peut-être ou alors peut-être chercher
des failles dans ces éléments tuteur
dans tous les cas c'est surtout
recentrer l'intérêt général sur sur le
la stratégie et le jeu qu'on va mettre
en place et faire abstraction du reste
les sur ce sur ce type de match je pense
que les joueurs d'expérience donc les
plus âgés de l'équipe ont un rôle
prépondérant
parce que certainement qui se sont déjà
déplacés à marcq-en-baroeul dans l'eure
dans l'eure et donc ils vont pouvoir
justement enlever un peu de stress aux
plus jeunes en leur expliquant où est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir se
ça comment ça va se passer c'est guidé
c'est une idée de groupe pour pour
justement évacués et vécu un peu un peu
un peu de stress vous allez vous appuyez
justement jean mis sur le capitaine les
joueurs d'expérience oui c'est assez
fort ses forces et il y en as raison on
s'appuie aussi sur des joueurs
d'expérience mais c'est avant tout et
c'est pendant ces matches là et ces
rencontres-là qui a vraiment les groupes
et les relations se font entre joueurs
c'est pas pendant la période du
championnat
c'est vraiment dans les phases finales
où on forme et on crée vraiment un
groupe et une entité aujourd'hui je peux
vous assurer que le groupe saignant il
et il est prêt il est prêt on est prêt à
les relever le défi a marqué mort vous
pensez que plaisir va se qualifier
oui mais on n'est jamais si vous auriez
ils auront les mêmes calvet vous l'avez
eue au match aller chemin que nous
restions parce que c'est une grosse
équipe on a fait une belle performance
maintenant je peux vous assurer que le
groupe est prêt le groupe est prêt avec
une unité est vraiment un état d'esprit
où là vraiment il ya quelque chose qui
s'est créée c'est forcément dans ces
vies dans ces phases finales où on
arrive à créer ce genre de d'émulation
un groupe qui s'est créée pour la
fédérale 2 j'espère un ont continué
cette page résultats par de la boxe a
dit lahm ou mady est redevenu champion
d'europe des poids super-moyens à 36 ans
treize mois après avoir perdu cette
ceinture le boxeur est lent courtois
s'est imposé sur les terres de
l'espagnol mariano hilario en battant
pointe les trois juges lui ont donné la
victoire après les 12 rounds disputés le
sportif affiche désormais un bilan de 21
victoires 1 nul et 4 défaites
on écoute le champion yvelinois micro de
camille lambert
je me sens plutôt bien et comptant même
fier de moi d'avoir amené cette ceinture
le combat était
stratégiquement bien bien conçu j'avais
une team qui avait eu l'oeil dessus on a
pu travailler sur les défauts d'hilario
comme les qualités d'hilario donc ça n'a
pas été un combat qui a été placé au
hasard on savait comment fallait le
boxer son objectif sera désormais
d'aller chercher un titre mondial dans
sa catégorie son objectif final avant de
raccrocher les gants
la question sur ce thème ce combat le
fait-il entré dans l'histoire de la boxe
en france
oui ou non voter il est tout de même
allé battre
du coup l'espagnol chez lui oui voilà
vous êtes sympas et les mains j'aime
bien voilà vous y croyez alors un petit
duel raul genlis allez-y genre les
courbettes à l'exigeant alors oui on va
laisser la parole en dernier au
spécialiste des spécialistes et insipide
j'ai dit j'ai dit non j'ai dit non parce
que
parce que déjà il avait déjà parlé ici
sur le plateau alors j'espère que j'ai
pas le croiser parce que on me l'a 36
ans est là maintenant pour moi un titre
champion champion de france double
champion d'europe
oui mais est-ce que ça le fait rentrer
dans l'histoire de la boxe en france
je pense quand même que on a d'autres
sportifs et d'autres non sa jetée du
tout je ne reviens elancourt ce n'est
pas loin de plaisir ces gens on ne sait
jamais je je je vais là je vais parole
mais non pour moi c'est non je pense
qu'en plus il aura est ce qu'il aura
vraiment l'opportunité parce que c'est
même pas le temps je veux pas une
question d'âge là je devance raul et
est ce qu'on va lui proposer pour
pouvoir et
obtenir un titre de champion du monde je
ne pense pas mais je suis pas un grand
spécialiste je pense qui lui prendra la
parole là dessus mais pour moi
il est pas rentré qu'un dans l'histoire
il marquera pas l'histoire de la boxe
française pour moi raul alors tout
d'abord je tiens à saluer la team
farrugia le club là où je pratique
également la boxe puisque adila est un
poulain de cette salle là j'ai eu la
chance de croiser parfois même les gants
avec lui pourquoi il rentre dans la
légende parce que mika au nom non
justement on prenait pas trop de risques
c'est vrai c'est très simple bienvenus
voilà mais faut savoir qui boxe dans la
catégorie des super-moyens c'est c'est
pas une catégorie dans lequel il ya eu
beaucoup de français de titres et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il entre dans
l'histoire de la boxe en france en tous
les cas
nous on avait suivi de très près ces
deux ans et deux ans de mise en place
pour récupérer son titre c'est du cdu a
dit là tout craché c'est à dire
énormément stratégie beaucoup de
réflexions d'ailleurs vous voyez quand
vous entendez parler c'est quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup de mesure et qui a pris
beaucoup de recul par rapport à sa
défaite et son son chaos
maintenant comme je l'avais dit moi je
le connais je le condamnait pas du tout
parce que 36 ans et peut-être vieux pour
intégrer le haut niveau mais c'est pas
si vieux que ça pour y perdurer floyd
mayweather raconte à 40 ans il a il a
défendu son titre mondial que cinq ou
six fois me semble-t-il
donc c'est pas grave peut-être à nouveau
à plus de 40 ans contre conor mc gregor
à la mais bon on verra sait pas encore
c'est pas encore signé mais tous les cas
dans l'écart grâce à de très près voilà
mes donc ça m'étonne pas maintenant
effectivement il est dans une catégorie
qui est très très relevé avec les deux
galas avec les smiths donc je sais pas
s'il aura accès au combat pour le titre
mondial
mais en tous les cas je le vois très
très bien défendre son titre une deux
fois et le gagner parce qu'il a il a plu
mener son combat comme il est comme il
le fait très bien il a donné beaucoup de
coups fatigué son adversaire à la tâche
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça qu'ils
gagnent au point et et voilà quoi bravo
a dit là et j'étais pas je suis pas du
tout étonnée de ce retour la juste moi
j'ai demi rouge parce que en effet je
pense pas qu'ils rentrent dans
l'histoire de la boxe parce que c'était
la question que vous posiez maintenant
maintenant faut quand même saluer la
belle performance est à dire que voilà
il avait pris 1 ko contre le même
adversaire au premier round de la
dernière fois on est bien d'accord une
minute 13 je crois ou minute trente a
été très rapide hélas
donc il reprend le titre au point à la
fin de la fin mais quand on le voit là
quelques jours après où il n'est pas du
tout marqué alors que spies qui l'avait
déjà battue déjà battu également pour
gagner la c1 contre moi je pense qu'il
peut il pourrait très bien rebattre
smith s'ils avaient une revanche je
crois pas que ce soit dans le plan
peut-être de galles d'abord et ensuite
la ceinture mais eux mais c'est vrai que
là les soutiens qu'il avait pris un
chaos
alors peut-être pas de chance
malencontreux un chaos sur sur le mode
précédent et là il fait un match et qui
va aller jusqu'à là jusqu'à son terme et
on le voit ou qui aurait dû être arrêtée
avant selon selon un deal à la corde
arbitre apparemment n'a pas de lune n'a
pas souffert il n'était pas du tout
marquer le doigt sur les images là donc
donc c'est on peut on peut quand même
vraiment le considérions ne verra les
cinq jours après son combat
pendant deux ans il n'a pas quitté la
salle où il est il est venu s'entraîner
il se maintenait en forme il est parti
faire un stage en espagne là avec marvin
d'ailleurs faut pas oublier que marvin
martin pour le pour la même ceinture
dans une semaine quasiment donc de 18
mais voilà contre ans un petit verre la
voix la centale avions déjà parlé dans
une précédente émission qui s'était
dérobé une semaine avant encore un gars
de la team farrugia mais bon après il
est vrai pour répression électro paille
de l'histoire de la boxe c'est vrai
qu'en france on a quand même à conduire
voile mardi au petit matin des champions
olympiques on ad d plusieurs champions
du monde dans d'autres catégories
et donc c'est vrai que je pense que
c'est maintenant ça commence à prendre
une autre ampleur la boxe olympique sur
et qui par rapport à un titre de
champion mais par rapport à la catégorie
et bien je suis allée super moyens c'est
très rare mais je suis pas je suis pas
assez je suis passé président dans ce
sport ce sport est trop compliqué pour
un pour des novices il ya trop de
fédération il ya trop de trop de titres
à droite à gauche et c'est vrai que ça
demande de ça demanderait simplification
pour pour que pour qaderi tu reçois
soient fiers beaucoup
le plus simple pour pour des novices et
ses fous là la presse qu'il avait deux
ici pasqua plus du média à l'étranger
par exemple n'est plus connu en italie
en france
ici des automates et toi avec 10 et
pourtant dans la rue alors qu'en france
à elancourt on l'a fait l'interview
justement nos studios
personne personne alors qu'en italie
c'est une superstar en voilà non mais il
garde la tête froide
c'est une vieille école la team farrugia
donc c'est des leçons d'humilité tout le
temps il a toujours été très proche de
nous et il va rester comme il est en
travaux on le voit il fait pas du tout
ce n'est pas du tout du showtime je
pense que vous avez vu michael qu'on
voulait l'interviewer il est très lucide
et sait ce qui lui rend service à on
sait pas on sait pas ce que l'avenir lui
réserve parce qu'il est il garde
énormément les pieds sur terre
bravo bravo bravo
hélène le fait également de battre
l'espagnol chez lui avec l' arbitre qui
était en plus espagnole pilar la plus ou
moins soutenu justement est-ce que ça
fait pas rentrer dans l'histoire de la
boxe de la boxe en france voilà il se
bat finalement contre tout le monde
non mais c'est ce genre oui c'est sûr
qu'ils cumulent était tout seul face à
que des espagnols s'appuient bunia pas
il avait peut-être pas public
spécialement pour lui et cumulent des
difficultés du stress etc
en même temps il devait avoir une sacrée
motivation aussi suite au chaos
précédent de récupérer donc si je pense
que s'il a vraiment le cette gnac là je
rejoins ce que tu disais
on peut avoir des surprises et le voir
soit gardé son titre soit allait
peut-être dans d'autres d'autres titres
d'autres championnats
c'est possible prend un pari avec vous
michael on a trois yvelinois champion
d'europe cet été je pense c'était marvin
on aura dit là et on ira on aura à
mettre mon m'a dit c'est ma terre
j'estime que je dois plus compliqué sur
le combat parce que les arbitres appelés
à abandonner les signalent par papa il
sous l'ampoulé peut pas donc c'est ça
mais avant nous et que j'avais une
relation c'est un peu compliqué genlis a
dit la sous faulx t-il également d'un
manque de reconnaissance tout simplement
de la boxe en france voilà il aurait
gagné ce combat là il ya 50 ans 40 ans
on aurait peut-être plus parler dans les
médias on aurait peut-être vu a dit là
où jt de 20h de tf1 peut-être la boxe
n'est pas que je vais quand même pas
partie des les disciplines médiatique en
france faut quand même reconnaître on
voit pas beaucoup de boxe
sur les médias avec la vie ça revient
petit redoux le sua
ça m'a fait un peu mais justement on
souffre adidas offre aussi un petit peu
ça c'est ça c'est ça le problème il est
là c'est qu'effectivement il n'y a pas
de secret si ceux ci dans les médias on
en parlait mais là bien sûr qu'ils
seraient connus parce que c'est quand
même un titre championne d'europe après
l'avoir perdu récemment iloilo ils
arrivent à leur conquête mais on n'en
parle pas beaucoup de la boxe donc après
pour pour des spécialistes comme raul
il est lui dans cette catégorie c'est
une grande performance mais pour pour
nous c'est pas un match de fin de soirée
deux parce que bon quand on quand on
arrête de se plaindre rock à plusieurs
matchs sur sur les gars là oui sur dix à
la voilà il ya plusieurs mois
c'est souvent une idée assez toujours le
dernier match mais le dernier match donc
commence souvent très tard ça c'est le
made in donc du coup donc du coup pour
être des alentours de 22h 23h la met
donc à 22 23 heures je suis désolé mais
bon même le week end
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont dormir
quand donc c'est compliqué de c'est
compliqué de suivre la mode car quand on
plus une actualité via via les réseaux
sociaux etc
mais c'est vrai que vouloir voir un
match en direct c'est toujours non puis
c'est vrai qu'il ne faut pas se cacher
c'est les promoteurs qui choisissent et
et c'est en fonction de la tête aussi du
boxeur et de ce sont sa manière des
actions delachaux et c'est marvin martin
il fait beaucoup plus salle comble quand
il boxe caddies là alors que marvin n'a
pas encore approché le titre mondial
donc voilà ça aussi c'est sûr c'est ce
que certains disent battant même dans
d'autres formes
compris vers la question raul il sera
champion du monde a dit là il sera
champion du monde raconte aussi la peur
de la perdre aux professionnels et maire
de cambon cap à deux il n'y a pas de
discussion l'atv sera champion du monde
à champéry objectif on va maintenant à
quitter cette page résultats pour passer
à notre coup de projecteur
un cadre prestigieux des cavaliers de
haut niveau 200 chevaux et un public de
connaisseurs le jumping international
cinq étoiles de versailles était
organisée du 5 au 7 mai dans les grandes
écuries du château
au casting de cette première édition des
champions olympiques tricolores comme
kevin staut originaire du chéné la star
du cinéma français comme guillaume canet
mais également l'une des légendes de ce
sport le brésilien de 44 ans rodrigo
pessoa médaille d'or aux jo de 2004 et
vainqueur de 50 grand prix on les écoute
il était au micro de tv fil 78
l'équipe d'organisation sont des amis
depuis depuis longtemps relaxé un de mes
partenaires aussi depuis 19 ans donc ils
m'ont demandé d'être ambassadeur du du
concours de l'événement j'ai bien
évidemment accepté donc il fait je
devais être ici est très très bons très
bons cavaliers c'est une compétition
très relevée sur les prochains jours
cette compétition peut être développer
encore plus l'équitation de haut niveau
dans le département avant de répondre je
vous donne quelques chiffres il ya
vingt-deux mille cinq cents licenciés
dans les yvelines
je me trompe pas raul c'est bon pour ses
bons 207 adoucissement équestre dont
celui de plaisir celui de raul
le jumping national fait partie des
douze plus grandes compétitions de
l'année en france
on va justement écouter le président de
la fédération française d'équitation sur
la question les yvelines vous savez
c'est un département très équestre et
cheval le fait qu'ils aient des grandes
manifestations etc est bien sûr
participe à la dynamique du cheval en
ile de france
le cheval en ile de france c'est 10% des
activités agricoles qui se déroule donc
il a une place importante c'est plus de
5000 emplois c'est plus de 500
établissements équestres donc bien sûr
ça ça démontre le dynamisme de notre
secteur et du cheval en particulier dans
notre région
la question sur ce thème cette
compétition peut-elle développer encore
plus l'équitation de haut niveau dans le
département vous votez oui ou non non
oui à raul est partagée on fait un petit
duel entre vous et l'aisne et yann vous
comment sais tu t'es trompé maintenant
tu assumes
j'étais rouge
jésus alors cette compétition peut-elle
développer encore plus équitation de
haut niveau dans le département bien sûr
mais je vois le monde d'accord jumping
attend à cela la vie voilà tout à fait
dans ce sens toutes ces compétitions
internationales qui se feront toutes
compétions internationales qui se
déroulera dans le département fera
permettra à n'importe quel sport d'avoir
un rayonnement sur le département le
moins f1 sur le vélo le vieux saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui il ya énormément de gens qui
ont découvrir une découvert cette
discipline grâce alors qu'il faisait du
vélo depuis très longtemps qu'on exerce
cette discipline grâce aux championnats
du monde aux championnats d'europe qui
aujourd'hui la pratique est donc un
effet de masse fait que les vôtres mais
de haut niveau bien sûr puisque l'effet
de masse fait que le haut niveau remonte
aussi alors maintenant dans le vélo il
va y avoir beaucoup de deux
problématiques à régler mais dans
l'édition rené puérari crowd je crois
que dans l'équitation il ya aussi le
même type de problème c'est vrai que les
détections
toutes ces choses là c'est des choses
qui n'accepte bilité du haut niveau
voilà c'est des choses qui sont qui sont
toujours problématiques mais mais il va
falloir la falloir y remédier mais en
effet a passionnément on à la masse je
pense que c'est plus facile d'accéder
enfin d'avoir du monde à haut niveau
donc c'était oui bien sûr j'étais pour
oui bah oui je suis désolé ce faux débat
avec cannes
vous êtes trop léger également oui moi
je sais pour lui je rejoinds ce qui est
dit le voilà puis on a deux participants
plus on a de d'adhérents et de
personne dans cette discipline la plus
on a de chances d'avoir un développement
au niveau par pareil
comme tu fais comme ils disent et comme
enfin comme tu disais comme ils disent
en cyclisme à surveiller à mettre en
place parce que c'est après ça peut être
la porte ouverte a donc forcément plus
de visibilité mais plus de licenciés
c'est pareil dans votre sport également
oui oui raul qui a raison qui a tort
plus alors on est tous d'accord d'accord
finalement pourquoi
oui et non parce que je sais pas si ça
va ça va faire augmenter le nombre de
licenciés ou faire que deux issus de
quadriller voilà on est déjà le plus
gros le plus gros contribuables de la
deux du nombre de licenciés en france
c'est pas c'est pas que ça va augmenter
le nombre de cavaliers haut niveau mais
ça va leur rendre service ça va
développer un petit peu leur image
médiatique
j'ai rien contre guillaume canet mais je
suis content michael que vous ayez
interviewé au lieu de servir des
interviewés guillaume vous ayez un
tableau des cavaliers de haut niveau
comme rodrigo pessoa une la famille
pessoa kiki c'est moi qui jouais en
france qu'est née justement à neuilly
est qui et qui
la famille sont des grands fervents de
duos du haut niveau et voilà que ça ne
soit on n'est pas besoin des stars pour
que attirer du monde sur nos concours
mais que nos cavaliers deviennent les
stars justement de ces concours c'est ça
qui est important
et quand on voit le nombre de
pratiquants en france on peut maintenant
je ne dis pas qu'il ya des plus de
mérite que dans d'autres sports mais
voilà maintenant je pense que la
couverture médiatique de nos cavaliers
ils la méritent donc
donc voilà pour ça ça rendra service à
c'est sûr parce que ça donne une
accessibilité supplémentaires et une
visibilité de nos cavaliers
il n'y a pas une saturation peut être un
plafond de verre qu'on pourra pas
déplacés finalement si je suis d'accord
avec vous on pourra pas dépasser 22500
vous pensez attention je pensais que
vous parlez du nombre de concours en
ile-de-france donc de concours ni de
france télévisions s'est déjà 5
on est déjà de loin le pays qui organise
le plus de 5 étoiles donc ça renforce un
petit peu ce classement là mais
non un plafond non je pense qu'il
faudrait réorganiser les structures et
trouver encore un nouveau un nouveau
système de démocratisation mais non je
pense que le plafond est pas être par
contre c'est vrai que tu as versailles
c'est top parce que voilà juste devant
le château comme ça ça fait une belle
image c'est sur les jurés étaient
également ouverts pour les visiteurs
j'ai couru au mans ce week-end et je
partais de versailles j'avais renoue
avec un ami et c'est vrai que ben pouvez
pas le rater on quand on se projette
devait se produire à versailles on
savait qu'ils avaient quelque chose qui
se passe est un petit peu de curiosité
c'était un bon tour de chauffe pour les
fils de la cellule du coup c'est une
bonne pub moi je trouve que enfin voilà
versailles on en attend enfin du fait
qu'il est le château
c'est dommage c'est la ville à référente
de daisy blinn et donc qui devrait
servir de vitrine mais comme il ya le
château elle a besoin de rien d'autre
pour rayonner ben du coup elle se sert
elle nous sert pas elle ne sert pas le
département a créé du développement et
donc on est obligé voiliers de de
s'extérioriser pour pouvoir organiser
des belles choses quant au tour de
france et est venu et a fait le départ à
versailles c'était c'était quand même
super sympa trois ombres peut-être le
même plus trois ans ont annoncé ses
actes si la victoire dans le grand prix
et brésilienne le cheval lui était
français est issu de l'élevage français
cabri de l'île dont je salue sont son
éleveur etienne poisson qui a fait
naître le chevalet qui les français les
français n'ont pas gagné à rioux c'est
juste un échange de 6,6 hilal et voilà
ça c'est des français gagnent à gré du
brésil et les brésiliennes en france
pourquoi pas mais le cheval était
promise c'était trop tôt près c'est trop
tôt pour évaluer l'impact réel
ils ont signé pour 3 ans sur ce jumping
à versailles est-ce que l'impact
finalement le bilan il faudra dans trois
ans pour savoir si ça eu un impact sur
les yvelines forcément façon un impact
on peut le contrôler que que quelques
temps après se plaint que le contrôle
est tout de suite n'y aura pas la
rentrée prochaine selon vous des
je nouveau cavalier pour moi je pense
pas je pense que c'est plus dans cette
discipline
un moment prestigieux parce qu'encore
une fois le lieu est prestigieux et
quand même il faut quand même
reconnaître que c'est une discipline où
on a beaucoup beaucoup de grandes
performances à haut niveau
on en parle malheureusement pas assez
c'est ce fait partie des sports mineurs
mais c'est bien dommage je coupe genlis
on va passer au prochain thème en face
maintenant notre logo du jour et
concerne la visite du cio apparaît dans
ce premier focus nous allons parler de
la visite du cio dans les yvelines dans
le cadre de la candidature de paris aux
jo de 2024 les membres du comité ont
visité ce lundi 15 mai le vélodrome de
ce national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et sa piste de bmx la collina
d'elancourt le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le château
de versailles
objectif évaluer les structures dans
l'optique de recevoir les épreuves
je ne vais pas vous poser des questions
sur ce thème enfin la question du thème
de ce thème
je vais vous demander vos recettes pour
séduire ce jury je fais un tour de table
il y en est ce que vous avez une recette
magique
pour les séduire non non je pense que
n'y a pas de recette magique dont les
infrastructures sont géniaux et je pense
que j'ai zappé sujet comme aux adultes
mais non il n'y a pas de recette je
pense que les infrastructures sont là et
ça c'est une vraie c'est vraiment
important
là je pense que ce qui peut séduire sur
sur le département c'est que tout est
relatif à tous tes proches des uns des
autres et c'est vrai que nous pour le
cyclisme tout va se dérouler sur sur
saint quentin et ça ça va être un vrai
pôle maintenant maintenant voilà on a on
a de très belles ben voilà on à
versailles qui qui qui nous permet de
rayonner d'avoir de deux superbes images
comme on disait justement pour le pour
jean ping tout et tout est déjà mis en
place et tout est lui déjà mis en oeuvre
pour qu'on puisse avoir deux bogeys aux
en france moi je pense que c'est
vraiment on est sur un
des vents favorables et et je vois pas
pourquoi on n'aurait pas de 1024 là je
pense que je peux dire que les jeux sont
faits mais pour moi il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on les gagne pas je n'ai pas
de recette miracle
le cio non non pas du tout il n est pas
du tout non s'y attendre c'est un oui
petite recette miracle a quand même on
prendre les jeunes du cio les mets
autour d'une bonne table access et a
commencé faire en les publiant fini la
journée avec une boîte de chenilles à la
soir à paris et je passais qui seraient
séduits par la capitale a quand même on
verra on va vous proposer peut-être pour
aller animer à saint quentin en yvelines
voilà raul est ce que la candidature se
joue dans les yvelines
voilà il ya quand même quatre sites
l'équitation le vtt le cyclisme sur
piste le golf et le pmu c'est une pierre
angulaire vraiment du projet parisien en
ile-de-france oui les yvelines vont
c'est peut-être un petit peu restreint
calme et surtout l'île de france il ya
quand même il ya quand même plusieurs
compétitions quand même qui se déroule
dans les vraies mais ce moment c est ce
que c'est une pierre angulaire un
endroit il ne faut pas se rater
abbas à ça tous les cas c'est un
fondamental c'est à dire que c'est
effectivement dans les sas est un organe
vital
maintenant ça des papas ça dépend pas
que de la sas étant un petit peu plus
juste que je parle pas que je
géographiquement mais mais bon ce qu'ils
veulent les fonds qui vont être
mobilisés que ce soit humain et même
économiques etc ne font pas que partie
des yvelines donc je pense que y'a pas
que aux yvelines qu'il faut pas se rater
c'est toute la france qu'on fait village
olympique doit certainement avoir une
grosse importance dans le
dans l'attribution de
des jeux olympiques son geste a déjà son
village olympique ça sera l'université à
200 du rsc façon probable occupa les
dossiers de son hd sur youtube donc
voila et ça ça peut avoir ça je pense
que ça peut avoir beaucoup plus
d'importance en terme de deux d'image
est il par contre peut-être davantage
que l'on a c'est que los angeles une
ville qui est très très très étendue et
là on a peut-être on a peut-être une
structure qui est plus qu est plus dense
pour pouvoir accueillir accueillir ces
jeux alors il ya un facteur également
hélène à prendre en compte
le cio a visité les infrastructures de
los angeles avant de voir celle de paris
est-ce que ça va jouer ou pas dans la
décision du cio
est-ce qu'il faut pas faire mieux après
finalement évidemment évidemment
maintenant
je peux pas trop répondre à cette
question parce que je ne sais pas je
pourrai pas comparer moi même donc je
devais juge s'il devait le juge
attendrait d'avoir visité les deux et
puis après je mettrai dans une colonne
les plus les moins de chaque et puis à
partir de là je prendrai ma décision
pour mettre mon bulletin dans la saison
6 années à larry smith il ya des fuites
par rapport au haut de la première
visite et que justement on peut tirer
des conséquences de ces appréciations
iliaque infectera pas un connecteur sur
les infrastructures notamment dans les
villes c'est qu'on a des grandes
compétitions qui vont être qu'ils vont
être organisées ou qui ont été
organisées la dir club
un bol sur litres en 2018 le chef du
monde
2000 et rodez voilà le vélodrome donc la
gamme des infrastructures qui aura
accueilli déjà des grandes compétitions
de niveau international et qui vont en
accueillir alors je pense que ça pour ça
c'est un savoir-faire aussi et dire
c'est déjà rodé pour un événement
international
donc ça je pense ça pèse énormément dans
la balance avant de l'acheminer bien sûr
ça sera le mot de la fin sur ce thème
c'est le moment passé à notre rubrique
débats dans cette émission jingle on va
commencer par un débat sulfureux il
concerne le football féminin l'équipe
première de voisins-le-bretonneux est en
grève depuis la mi-avril les filles
protestent contre le renvoi de leur
coach wilfrid des rushes une décision
prise par le président antoine restore
cheli la raison l'achat de sacs de sport
par l'entraîneur sans l'aval du
président
les dix sept joueuses ont donc décidé
d'être solidaire du coach on regarde les
déclarations justement des joueuses chez
nos confrères des nouvelles de
versailles la décision a été très dure à
prendre car on était première du
championnat en demi finale de la coupe
des yvelines la capitaine de l'équipe
christelle basque rajoute que les filles
n'ont plus envie de porter le maillot de
voisins on ne reviendra pas sur notre
décision de son côté le président a
déclaré à la presse on va le voir
justement à l'écran on continuera avec
celles qui auront envie de rester et
d'autres qui nous rejoindrons comme
chaque année voilà ça ne sonne le nom ni
pas plus que ça il y avait tout de même
donc un objectif sportif à pouvait
monter d'une division cette saison elles
sont actuellement en promotion de ligue
c'est vraiment dommage de rater le coche
vraiment y en a je pense qu'elle
soutient hans porte je pense qu elle se
tire une balle dans le pied
bon
maintenant
[Musique]
maintenant je pense que l on
complètement raison de pouvoir de d'être
de soutenir leur leur coach parce que
parce que en effet il ya eu une
maladresse une maladresse ou on n'a pas
prévenu de résident pour pour x raisons
mais mais les résultats sportifs étaient
là et il ya un moment où ça doit aussi
seraient compensées et ça doit
et voilà c'est tout le club doit tout
mais voilà pour l'achat de onze 11 sacs
on limoge le coach autre chose à faire
est certainement juste deux cafés bondés
aussi alors la question sur ce thème
une grève justifiée ou scandaleuses
justifiée aux scandaleuses justifier la
scandaleuse rouge scandaleuse pour
justifier mais je soutiens mais c'est
vrai que je trouve ça dommage son ca
dommages peuvent être partagés quand
même je dis quand même question une
balle dans le pied au départ c'est
dommage de lâcher que j'ai de lâcher le
titre et de lâcher deux fois la coupe
divine wind journée est-ce que c'est
scandaleux ou justifier l économie
soutiennent leur coach comme ça alors je
pense qu'on l'a qu'à un pote plus
d'informations parce que on n'a pas
marché de la formation
oui parce que là moi ça me paraît ça me
paraît ahurissant qu'un lien et
résultats sportifs en limoges un
entraîneur pour l'achat de sacs de sport
je pense quand même qu'on n'a pas tous
des informations et de les voir on avait
aimé acheter des sacs de sport a appelé
la police l'algérien achetez donc ça va
je suis pas limogé mais non mérités -
abyad
à mon avis il ya un souci un autre souci
certainement relations entre le
président et l'entraîneur et que c'est
peut-être l'excusent qu'il a trouvé pour
le renvoyer
mais on peut pas renvoyer un coach qui a
des résultats sportifs en plus c'est son
boulot entre guillemets cresson c'est
sûr nous ne pas le renvoyer pour
simplement l'achat de sacs de sport j
proposera des choses c'est plutôt au
niveau des joueuses s'est justifié ou
scandale après après après sportivement
l'achat et le club dans lequel h le club
et qu'elle avait au président c'est
aussi leur droit maintenant sportivement
il faut savoir où on en est on fait du
sport c'est pour gagner moi je suis un
compétiteur donc après faire grève
et puis condamné le club sportivement
donc je pense qu'on n'a pas toutes
toutes les informations parce que c'est
celle amenant manière à elle de faire
payer la latitude de leur président en
dix ans mais voilà on n'est pas d'accord
du tout on n'est pas d'accord du tout
sur le nîmois joue avec un maillot de
boisés je ne peux pas vous dire là
dessus est-ce que c'est également au
c'est un comportement finalement
honorable de faire grève voilà dans le
football moderne où on décrit souvent
les joueuses qui lâchent leur coach
finalement le lâchent pas leurs coaches
font grève parce qu'elles veulent tout
simplement l'avoir dans l'équipe
un coach qui les a fait gagner et qui
pourrait continuer faire gagner à
l'avenir moi je condamne absolument
cette grève
quand on a dix-sept je la condamne tout
à fait on a vu ce que ça a donné à une
échelle nationale enfin internationale
alors là je suis je pense que je suis un
groupe traumatisé de ça donc
alors voilà comme ça s'est passé au
rugby
j'avais trouvé ça y des messieurs et
j'étais je m'étais dit mais les
rugbymans qu'on pensait être un milieu
de faire salle se met à le faire aussi
on doit rester à pau dit à politiser
quand on est un sportif et le maillot
que l'on porte doit doit doit passer
avant toute chose la solidarité par
rapport à son coach ça peut le faire de
plus de plusieurs d'autres manières mais
en tous les cas il faut on doit répondre
présent quand on est quand on joue un
rôle de joueur quand on a du monde
derrière soi quand on a des sponsors
quand on a de l'argent qui est mis
moi je condamne je condamne toute forme
de grève sauf faute grave
et encore on n'a pas tous les éléments
mais et je suis coach également donc je
reconnais tout l'importance d'un coach
et la fidélité qu'on lui doit et est en
tous les cas j'en suis sensible en ce
qui me concerne mais pour moi on doit
rester un joueur de rester un joueur et
la politique c'est la politique mais je
ne pas interférer vous gens vous seriez
dans la même situation que l'entraîneur
où il ferait des roches pour trouver la
même situation est ce qu'on vous
soutenez vos joueurs à dire il faut
faire grève ou vous leur conseille
plutôt de finir le championnat
non moi un plaisir si le président me
virer les joueurs seraient trop quotas
il s'agirait pas de dire il serait trop
quotas ne veut faire lors des villas à
trépas il était jusqu'au bout quand à sa
les motiverait peut-être me tiens si je
faisais lourdes et non dans les banques
des dizaines visa pas jeu c'est
particulier ça veut dire quand ça veut
dire qu'il ya une grande solidarité
quand même et le bel état d'esprit entre
les joueurs et le coach
donc ça c'est je rejoins petit peu raul
le côté sportif mais après quand même
l'état d'esprit est là et elle veut le
sauver leur coach d'une manière ou d'une
autre
alors d'après mes infos les joueuses
devraient tout partir de l'année
prochaine dans les clubs des alentours
voilà pour information voilà de vrais
dans les autres clubs de saint quentin
en yvelines
alors on va maintenant parler d'un sujet
qui concerne des milliers de cyclistes
en france et même à travers le monde la
sécurité chaque année plus de 150
cyclistes sont tués sur les routes est
près de 4000 sont blessés en france ans
dernièrement c'est le cycliste yoann
offredo qui a fait le buzz sur internet
suite à une agression dans la vallée de
chevreuse le sportif a été attaqué à
coups de cutter et de battes de
base-ball alors qu'il s'entraînait ce
sport est il trop dangereux nous avons
posé la question à des cyclistes
il ya de plus en plus d'accrochages en a
partout en région et alors
il y en a fredo on affirme donc ça ce
sont des têtes d'affiché mais tous les
jours espace des accrochages entre
cyclistes et
et automobilistes vaut mieux apprendre
partager la route c'est très dangereux
sur la piste car on est tous en pignon
fixe on peut pas arrêter de péri est sur
la route on appâte on n'a pas de quoi
s'entraîner sur la route c'est on est
avec les automobilistes et certains en
s'entraînant je vois avec nous ils
veulent pas nue sur la route il ya
quelques semaines une et trois heures
avec ça est vraiment faire attention
c'est vraiment dangereux
le danger du vélo c'est con à la route
donc les voitures après comme je dis
faut apprendre à partager la route
allait pas convaincu en nico vélo est
donc aujourd'hui bâches et qu'il ya
beaucoup de pistes cyclables qui seront
notamment vers chez moi vers la suisse
ait beaucoup de pistes cyclables
ce sport est il trop dangereux vous
votez oui ou non trop dangereux trop
mais ce bar braque ou est-ce que c'est
trop dangereux par rapport à la route on
voit offredo on voit froome qui a des
problèmes également qui s'est fait
renverser ce que c'est un sport trop
dangereux mais même au niveau de la
piste dont jeu par rapport à quoi par
rapport aux automobilistes par rapport à
août sur la route mais en général parce
que c'est un sport trop dangereux ou si
vous êtes indécis rouler sera tranché
après ouais trop dangereux oui ou non
rojas et oui oui ça je serai bien plus
généreux dont jean paul ii que le bol
des malheureux ce nom alors elle
non je pense pas que ce soit non pas de
débat pourquoi alors on peut déjà on
peut pas on peut pas dire que c'est
dangereux ou pas à cause d'une agression
déjà ça ça devrait même pas avoir lieu
après je pense que ceux qui qui voilà
qui s'entraîne en milieu naturel
ico hills ils sont censés savoir ce
qu'ils font aussi voilà on peut pas
faire que de l'entraînement en salle et
c'est bon c'est du vélo c'est cédor quoi
donc c'est ça se fait d'or puis après on
peut pas condamner une pratique parce
que voilà il se passe des sexy dans
espace des agressions ces gens après
j'espère services tm du spécialiste du
par après alors moi je dis que c'est pas
dangereux j'ai dit que c'était là debout
iraqui bout en bout c'est pas dangereux
c'est tout simplement parce que et comme
l'a dit hélène les cyclistes s'entraîne
sur la route et ils font l'objet ni plus
ni moins mais d'accidents courant de la
circulation et par parent part je dirais
maladresse mais
[Musique]
mais phénomène phénomène quotidien sur
la route de leur part ou de la part des
automobilistes qu'ils rencontrent c'est
ce côté là là on voit on voit des
blessures mais c'était sur des courses
certains miser sur les contres
là ça n'a rien à voir le est ce que
c'est la dangerosité suppan à
l'entraînement sur la route ou moi par
exemple j'habite e gif sur yvette je
vais à plaisir le d'image
la nouvelle jungle où tu croises de 3,6
jade ou même paquet donc forcément est
ce que si cette majorité dont on parle
de leur six sacres n 1 sur la route au
milieu de la circulation normales et
classiques et là dans ce cas de figure
il rate simplement dans les cas
fréquents d' accidents de la route
est ce que c'est le sport après leur
sport purement et simplement
et moi je trouve que leur sport purement
et simplement n'est pas plus dangereux
que qu'un service vélo à type de loisirs
voilà lorsqu'elle mène également eu des
chutes vous y étiez à la course à
l'américaine la coupe de france
américaine et également des chutes
gagner c'est normal en compétition il ya
toujours des chutes
il ya des cons peut-il y ait des chutes
en compétition équestre il ya des chutes
enfin au rugby on sait aussi maintenant
ça ça fait partie du sport
moi la plus grosse problématique
aujourd'hui j'avais a beaucoup apprécié
un une phrase de yoann offredo dans un
de ces interviews 100 % des cyclistes
sont automobilistes l'un vers ce n'est
pas vrai mais ça c'est une belle phrase
à une belle phrase à retenir et c'est
vrai que donc moi quand je cours je suis
en voiture et que je croise un groupe de
cyclistes je sais comment interagir par
rapport à l'or à leur réaction et non je
sais ce qui va ce qu'ils comment ils
vont anticiper l un est par contre bien
un automobiliste lambda 9 n'aura pas
cessé ne pourra pas anticiper et ne va
pas comprendre le fonctionnement du
groupe de vélo donc peut-être qu'il ya
une formation à faire
au moment de prendre fin de
l'apprentissage de la conduite peut être
quelque chose à une sensibilité à
apporter c'est ce que yoann disait
maintenant il rencontre comme une grosse
problématique c'est que ben il ya quand
même de plus en plus de voitures sur les
routes
moi j'avais il ya quelques années j'ai
fait un stage en quad en balade en forêt
et je me souviens d'une des premières
remarques d'instructeurs c'est que le
quad étant arrivé le dernier en forêt il
n'a pas priorité ni sur les motos ni sur
les chevaux ni sur les piétons est en
fait le premier qui donc si jamais vous
croisez un piéton vous arrêter pour
laisser passer la priorité pour nous la
priorité aux piétons je pense que tu
peux être le confirmer et il ya une un
code qui est qui et celui là mais il
faut pas oublier quand même que le
cycliste était là avant l'automobiliste
le vélo a hésité avant l'avant la
voiture le fait le boulot mais non mais
donc peut-être qu'il ya un moment où il
faudrait aussi respecter respecter
cycliste nous on a notre seule
carrosserie
c'est notre seule autre casque quand les
gens quand les gens en porte et c'est là
aussi où je voulais il faut peut-être
aussi faire la différence entre un
accident comme tu disais quelqu'un qui
fait de la promenade qui va acheter sa
baguette de pain et qui va rentrer dans
l'accident de dans l'accident de du
cycliste avec la avec l'automobiliste
est le cycliste qui fait qui va faire
son entraînement et qu'il y ait une
wasla ken rées connaissance et qui sait
aussi se comporter sur la route même si
beaucoup de cyclistes dont j'ai pu faire
partie ne sont pas toujours très
respectueux des automobilistes à laisser
de côté le comportement
rendement et dans les deux bien sûr
voilà il ya eu également quelques chutes
dangereuse voire mortelle chez les
champions ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines et unique tenir
scarponi vainqueur du tour d'italie en
2011 qui est décédé et quelques jours
après une collision avec une camionnette
il ya chris froome triple vainqueur du
tour de france qui a eu également un
problème la semaine dernière champions
pas finalement tout le monde est à
l'avancé à l'entraînement il la route on
utilise tous les mêmes les tarés
d'automobilistes on rencontre aussi tous
les mêmes et donc il ya un moment où
vous pouvez faut pas oublier que comme
vous avez une deux fois deux voies
donc une voie dans un sens ou une fois
une voie l'automobiliste a le droit de
prendre le cycliste alors à de prendre
la moitié de la voiture était une ceci
tu sais on est on doit pas être à 20 cm
dans l'entretoit on a le droit à la
moitié d'une voix et ça ça fait partie
du du code du code de la route et en
plus le tout en glisse quand ils
doublent marland devrait prendre une
marche sécurité d'un mètre cinquante
on voit maintenant avec l'aso de plus en
plus de vidéos de d'actes
d'automobilistes qui sont vraiment
à cent lieues de son but de cela est ce
que le cycliste n'a pas un comportement
à risque en se déportant sur la gauche
parfois dans des montées dans des côtes
il faut bien à droite on a besoin à la
moitié on avoir la moitié d'une voix
quand même ça permet j'ai pas une voix
on va faire plus de trois mètres ça
permet d'avoir d'avoir un débattement
d'un mètre cinquante mais le problème
c'est que ben l'automobiliste il est
dense on tient en laisse et qu'il adore
roulant groupe par exemple mais alors la
la cycliste qui auront leur groupe en
effet on est chacun a un côté de l'autre
maintenant je vais faire un dessin mais
il est plus facile de doubler faut bien
rentrer je fais juste mon dessin il est
plus facile de doubler un groupe de
cyclistes de six personnes qui va être
comme ça que six cyclistes qui vont être
les uns les autres sur une sur une route
donc en effet c'est vrai que ça prend un
peu plus de place en largeur mais quand
vous allez pouvoir les doubler le
l'automobiliste il aura moins de temps
il mettra moins de temps et doubler une
voiture qui va arriver qui arrive en
face et ne va pas se rabattre sur les
cyclistes et aujourd'hui tout le monde
le comprend pas et ça c'est un ça fait
partie de l'éducation des deux de la
prévention qu'il faudrait peut-être
apporter en nous on passe notre notre
code ou nous tout est permis de conduire
et de doute ça laisse de toute façon le
je veux dire au niveau du
au moment où il va doubler il est quand
même sens et enfin il peut empiéter sur
la voie d'à côté qu'il empiète d'un
mètre d'un demi mètre ou d'un mètre
cinquante on s'en fout fish est et on
remarque enfin moi j'ai remarqué que les
automobilistes souvent roule sur leurs
voisins des portes à peine en pensant
que le cycliste de lui-même pas se
mettre plus à droite possible en fait
finalement c'est un peu ce que tu
rejoins le la moitié de la voix
l'automobile c'est pense pas forcément
bonjour pense maintenant qu'il ne sont
pas du tout adaptés à la pratique du
cyclisme qu'elle soit adaptée à la
pratique de la balade du dominical mais
aujourd'hui pour nous c'est impossible
de rouler sur une sur une piste cyclable
ça et les gens ne comprennent pas
toujours
ça sera la fin désolé vous couper à
noter l'absence de sarcelles on a bossé
là on parlera peut-être plus tard si
c'était un accident malheureusement
dramatique qui à l'image du site vous
avez vous occupé entre j c'est la fin de
cette émission merci nous avons suivi on
se retrouve le jeudi 25 mai pour un
nouveau numéro de six ans par les sports
à bientôt sur tv fil 78
[Musique]